so usually I have an initial
conversation when they sign me up for a
project and I'll probably talk to the
director and the series producer at the
exact about what they're proposing to do
more is it kind of just filling me in on
the project and then they might say have
you got any ideas occasionally they'll
do two or three shoots so they might
show me some rushes from the first shoot
or give me a ring and say oh we've got
this and taught me through anything I
mean it that's not necessarily when all
productions often I just come in on the
first day of the edit and they'll be
completely briefed them but in the early
stages I'm quite like to be left alone a
lot with the material and go through the
rushes and get a feel for them so I mean
I'm editing a huge long feature talk at
the moment so that stage lasted quite
long time like weeks or something a bit
shorter that would last less time more
like a few days and then sometimes the
director will drop in after a while and
then when it when we get nearer the wire
often it's working with a director of
viewing and making changes together but
I there's quite a lot of talking in
between and I also quite like breaking
you know you know I need frequent breaks
so I'll definitely always get up and
have a walk and go out at lunchtime and
kind of a bit of chat to break the ice
it was find so I started out really
early on my career working as an
assistant everything to a small director
a very small independent production
company and we were going out shooting
programs on poets in New York and I was
literally doing the 80 returned camera
assisting everything that he didn't do
and then we got into the Edit and he
sort of showed me how to edit in a way
and so I got a feel for it and then he I
guess encouraged me I persuaded him to
buy an avid it was really early days of
that so I kind of in this year I done I
had a degree in architecture so I quite
liked structure and I hope some familiar
with computers I mean it you know but
nowadays those storage block
costs of I know nine grand or something
ridiculous for about three gigabytes I
mean it was insane so that's that's how
I got into it and then I for a while
like toyed between going the directing
route or the editing route but actually
I hated banging phones and I was happier
in the dark playing around I think it's
having to make something it's this
process of not really knowing that in
the my favorite documentaries to work on
ones where the directors excited about
the material but nobody's got really an
idea in hell of how it's gonna what the
films gonna look like at the end and so
it's really scary being in the dark
you're sort of like plunging into this
abyss but it's also quite exhilarating
and exciting and it you know it's not
it's not easy but I seem to be addicted
and then there is also kind of fear is
it's fine it's being able to it sounds
cliche but it's being able to tell
people's stories and having this
relationship although it's not a live
relationship with contributors it's
being able to distill something about
them into a way that other people can
understand understand them and hopefully
kind of illuminate some bigger issue or
thing I think as always it was structure
it was how a lot of the stories were
quite similar so how do you make one
person's story distinct from the other
one and that was the hutt yeah that was
the hardest thing we work we work a lot
with index cards and there were quite a
few iterations of scenes going on and
characters that would come in and then
we would drop them yeah that's that was
probably the biggest challenge and and
also getting some of the scenes down
it's just as always choosing which which
parts you actually want and I think it's
very very easy I mean it's what I call
kind of sort of poverty porn or distress
porn like you know you've there's a
really delicate balance between being
sensationalist and showing a necessary
amount of distress and suffering that
that you get your message across and
I mean Louie's really good at that
anyway but Cook tonally with humor he
does amazing things with humor and
breaks the ice and so for me it's
bringing it's bringing Louie's
sensibility and my sensibility in the
direct sensibility on that altogether
and we have we do have a lot of
discussions about tone and always that
joke to march or and lose quite aware of
that so yeah it's really great
collaborating with him she's why I've
done it a lot I think we all want what's
best for the film and there's very
little ego involved so and and he's very
funny it he'll always he never takes it
he also never takes it too seriously
I think it takes the story very
seriously but there's never any blame or
awkwardness or discomfort in the Edit so
it's yeah it's always a pleasure
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]